hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey and I'm a dirtball
Rachel and last night we saw Mary
Poppins return a highly anticipated
movie of December forget spider-verse
forget Aquaman it's all about Mary
Poppins returning guys listen before we
hop into this review I wanted to say
thank you to all who have been following
us on the Stardust app over there we do
30 second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and trailers a lot of them are
micro sketches actually I believe
Rachel's on there as well yes I am yes
she is so go ahead download the app
follow us first before Tefal Rachel you
know it's free to download free to you
so do it today and you can post your own
reactions too
yes oh I never mentioned that yeah it's
really amazing to mention no you must
only watch never post anyway Mary
Poppins returns guys look you've seen
the trailers you know Mary Poppins is
about she's back in action okay there
you go plot description out of the way
and it's the longest it's been for a
sequel ever over 50 years yes well it's
funny how after they come back over 50
years they do a movie that's almost beat
for beat the same movie in a lot of ways
although what I'll give it is that what
they really added those unique element
to its beats not like like totally
unique but differ from the first one
there's a real specific ticking time
clock to this movie where the first one
doesn't really have that this one has
this element where Michael is all gone
Christopher Robin on us he hates being
an adult at a very specific time in
England he's exactly had a Christopher
Robin in this movie the overworked
father if it was about the dad it would
just be that movie similar to the first
Mary Poppins it kind of is about the dad
in the end like the arc of it all - well
if he had a screen yeah he doesn't
really have significant screen time the
ticking time clock to it is that they're
about to lose their house so they have
five days to find the certificate of
shares to the bank so that
they can have money to pay off the loan
that they have to the house and so you
have this very specific clock which
gives it a more sense of urgency
throughout but in the midst of that it's
the same beats of the first one but in
the middle of that I mean I still think
with Ben Whishaw it was a great job in
the film though yeah and again to be
fair you know they do the thing that
they've done in so many movies were like
he has a wife that's passed away and
he's all sad and he doesn't spend time
with his children but to be fair he
sings a song about how much he misses
his wife which was emotional yeah I got
a little teary listening to that song he
was in the beginning the movie to also
to be fair is not like they're touching
on oh he's over working has no time for
his kids it's more like oh he is like
worrying too much and maybe he just
needs to just sit back and see the
important things in life I think I just
appreciated that it wasn't exactly the
whole like hey you need to stop working
hard dad it wasn't that enjoying the
story at a point where things seemed
pretty normal for them and like they're
a pretty happy family it's just that
when the bank people show up then the
problem arises it doesn't seem as much
like oh you've just worked yourself into
a hole over time yeah the movie starts
out really energetically and then that
carries across the whole film is sort of
this energy I'm not the biggest Rob
Marshall fan in general but I really
thought he did a great job I think if
you're a fan of the firt if you're a big
fan of the first Mary Poppins movie and
I think if you're a fan of musicals in
general these kind of films I think
you're really gonna like this movie a
lot there's a lot of energy to it
there's a lot of imagination to it I
really love Julie Andrews and the first
Mary Poppins like most people but I
thought Emily Blunt really made it her
own in this movie I thought she was
fantastic in this film I'm not gonna see
here we go which one do I prefer I think
that emily Blunt's portrayal really
stands on its own and is great for this
time I really loved her in this film
like when she's on screen she really
commands it she's great yeah and it was
so great about emily Blunt's performance
is that just like Julie Andrews she can
be strict when she needs to be but then
also she can be very charming at the
same time yeah there's always this big
mystery with Mary Poppins especially
with like the first movie you don't
always know what her deal is like she's
very strict and then she'll deny
everything like when you say like oh but
you just did that it's just like I don't
know what you're talking about was dick
move
but there's always this mystery to it
and I just really appreciate that Emily
Blunt was able to embody that really
well strict and stern but also very
charming and sweet and just you just
can't help but to love her and she can
say another thing I really appreciate
about this movie is that it's a movie
musical with big-name stars who can say
yeah I one of my biggest pet peeves with
movie musicals is when you get people
who just can't sing and they're only
there because of the star power and this
one was really really well done well I
think a couple at least of the songs
were actually shot using set sounds so
that actually helps in a number at least
the couple songs where that appears it
was a nice breath of fresh air did he
just say fresh air you mentioned the
song that Ben Whishaw sings for the
beginning of the movie that's actually
one of my favorite musical moments
because one of the big stakes for a
movie like this is will the music be as
timeless and memorable as the original
films music is and I don't know if that
will be the case but I do think that
there are some musical moments that
stand out and are pretty dazzling
especially when you get deeper into the
movie the more fantastical elements
start to come out yeah it wasn't crazy
about the first musical bit because it's
mostly CGI that just becomes very
apparent amid the period peace stuff but
when they do the like 2d animation stuff
and some of the bigger and more ensemble
based musical numbers I really started
to appreciate the tradition this movie
was keeping alive to come back to Mary
Poppins I thought it was really really
wonderful and and there's so much to
appreciate in the way that they bring
back the tradition of these big you know
sweeping musicals yeah yeah yeah I
really think that if you haven't seen
the first Mary Poppins though you just
won't really appreciate this film I find
it very difficult to believe I had only
seen the first one for the first time
ever a few days ago so to watch this I
was like oh I would have been wildly
lost a lot of this is really built off
of your nostalgia factors for Mary
Poppins but really it really isn't that
way big and it's so funny because the
movie in so many ways is so charming but
at the same time yeah there is just very
reliance this is kind of here because a
lot of this kind of stuff was in the
past movie and there's a lot of beats
that are hit on from the last year too
even though like it's very unique and
distinct in some ways but then it's also
insanely familiar in some ways it's the
definition of same but different
but it was still really charming it was
you know I don't really remember the
songs I don't eat but I remember the
sequences better yeah like you know
instead of going into the painting they
go into a pot which is essentially the
painting sequence in the first movie
yeah I remember a lot of the imagery
there or instead of them cleaning the
room and they're going into a bathtub
and I remember a lot of the sequences
there but I don't really remember the
song I realized that - I didn't really
walk out of there humming any of the -
yeah not even the last one which was
like so lively and so beautiful but yet
visually it's socially lin-manuel
Miranda arguably gets more things to do
he can sing and he can really sell it
and he's charming even though he really
is kind of a Bert knockoff a lot of this
movie are the children's day for Murray
care there's a lot of people are just
supplements for these characters from
the original arguably that I think that
choreography dance moves that I remember
the most come from one of his sequences
in the film there was something about
when he's not seen that was distracting
to me I've never heard lin-manuel
Miranda before in my life I've never
heard an interview but when he was doing
his dialogue scenes he kind of delivers
every line the same way so I had me
going that's probably not his real
accent and I was very distracted
whenever he was doing just lines every
line was delivered the same way no I
mean it was kind of putting on the
accent thing again just like Dick Van
Dyke because there's always been this
one thing within the first movie like
while Dick Van Dyke is wonderful and
very charming and very happy in the
first movie you can't deny that cockney
accent is not good it's not good and I
don't know I kind of got the same
feeling here too but he was again still
charming and I still give him props for
bringing the you know just the energy
into this movie it was great I mean I
found him very charming he was one of
the elements I was looking forward to
the most because yeah I like him
generally I've not seen Hamilton I've
heard a lot of the music yeah and oddly
enough while I did enjoy watching him
and I did feel the joy coming off of his
character I did feel like he was perhaps
the one element of the cast that sort of
stuck out and didn't quite coalesce
because he seemed kind of
mirror than everybody else in the movie
to me I hate to say it but I almost felt
like it was one of those things worried
someone who was clearly used to being on
stage more of the time is now having to
adapt to the screen I thought yeah that
some of his subtleties weren't that
subtle a lot of guys delivery was pretty
like time but again he had one of my
favorite musical numbers in the whole
movie with all the Leary's and stuff
like that dick Van Dyke's in here oh my
god which is ruining the trailer first
of all you guys were there and the
audience that we were with when Dick Van
Dyke walked through the door the
audience applauded yeah they were so
excited to see him if you don't know
dick Van Dyke is in his early 90s oh it
shows he was tap dancing in this and he
was oh I was worried it's like you know
but like short little appearance that he
had in the movie I don't love this movie
I don't dislike this movie I enjoyed it
I didn't I did enjoy this movie I think
Emily Blunt does a great job in this
movie and I think the supporting cast is
also really good there was no character
other than Emily Blunt that I really
loved in this film I think that if you
don't see the first one you won't really
care for this one I think the
choreography individuals stand out way
more than the actual musical numbers do
but I still think there's a lot of fun
to be had like even when I was kind of
not really paying attention to the
lyrics I was still like able to enjoy
what I was what was being put in front
of my face the entire time yeah so yeah
I'd recommend if you're a fan of this
kind of thought thing I think you'd
really like it yeah if you are a musical
fan or just love the original Mary
Poppins then you will definitely I think
enjoy this but I think as Greg said like
if you haven't seen the first one
probably won't be a little bit lost but
visually it's great music is really good
not super memorable but still very
charming charming just you know wasn't
amazing yeah I feel like the true stars
of this movie for me were just the
imagination overall the cast overall and
the tradition of the kind of movie
they're trying to make all those
elements really swept me up really
dazzled me as a story you know like
we've said is it's
a familiar especially if you're familiar
at all with Mary Poppins so in a way I
wish this would open up the door for
Disney using all these resources that
they clearly still have to make things
like this that don't have to be locked
into a familiar bubble yeah if you care
at all about Mary Poppins I think you're
gonna really have a good time at this
yeah all right guys well Mary Poppins
returns do you want Mary Poppins Rises
the movie that's my one zombie place in
modern-day England you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell make sure to
check out adorable Rachel's YouTube
channel and also down low to follow us
on the Stardust at people where you can
post your own reactions to hold for
laughter all right now Rachel leave the
video